that does seem like a gap for you to
have troy to not know much about
seinfeld what was it i'm recording by
the way it's a show from the 90s
sitcom no i'm trying to think of like
why
why was it that um
[Music]
i oh that's [ __ ] weird i never
particularly like seinfeld but i've
watched a lot of it
uh yeah i don't think i've ever seen
episodes really
wait mike you haven't either no it's
completely possible
so hard right now see i'm i'm a huge fan
of frasier
um and right as a kid so i feel like i
was watching
frasier around the same time that
seinfeld was popping off maybe i don't
know
those were those were definitely
concurrent yeah were they
yeah i thought frasier would would
probably date i think it probably
started before seinfeld but they both
both were in reruns by the time me and
alana would have been watching them i
see
but you do understand where fraser came
from right yes sir
yes okay i've also seen cheese but was
more of a fan of frasier
[Laughter]
was that good it was that close pitch is
too good
that's such a weird thing too like i i
feel like um
cheers got divorced and you had to
choose between mom or dad and frasier
was
was dad obviously and then the mom was
uh baby newworth had her own show too
and that didn't do well um but like
give them shows come on he's going to
watch a woman who's going to such a
predicament
i will say this i think that true um
what's her name julie louise dreyfus is
the
dave grohl of tv in the sense that
all of the talent of seinfeld was
like all of the talent of nirvana the
the biggest or not the all the talent
but the biggest talent of nirvana
was dave grohl i so disagree
about seinfeld being carried by her
have you watched veep yes no no i i
don't think the seinfeld was carried by
her
you'll say the talent was transferred to
her
at the end or or just was their present
all along
and was made manifest in veep if you
ever watched veep
her her comedic ability and her dramatic
ability is
i understand why she has won so many
emmys
doesn't that just mean that she she was
the most versatily talented of the group
to be able to go off and do just
other things and continue to flourish
doesn't that mean
[Music]
i mean is that not the inherent
definition of being dave girl
yeah yeah what has kurt cobain done
after nirvana
yeah for real you don't hear from him so
much you don't have oh it's really
strange wonder what happened
wasn't seinfeld wasn't the whole thing
that was a show about nothing
yeah yeah so in a way we're the
spiritual success of the seinfeld we are
it works
what a the thing that i do respect about
seinfeld is that
jerry seinfeld apparently had a um
there was a uh um
a philosophy or whatever about the show
that they would never hug
and that no characters would ever learn
anything they definitely don't progress
one iota that's the genius of it is that
the pilot and the
series finale form this perfect circle
there's definitely no
there's definitely no sort of movement
or growth
as a writer that would drive me nuts i
would be so
sick fighting though right back in the
day that's how all those that's i mean
that's kind of how like
star trek next generation works right
like i do love that show any of those
shows what do you mean
what do you mean how you have to because
you're in syndication you have to end in
the same place as you start whereas
what what what austin's saying is that
that was like that was a feature
of seinfeld rather than a bug they lent
into it
whereas i think a lot of shows there was
that weird period where they were
starting to go towards the serialized
like
there was that urge in television to
tell long-form stories so you get that
in kind of
ds9 yeah like it starts to creep in
yeah like yeah back in the day like
every show was meant to be completely
watchable
it was it was it was a big yeah it was a
big deal when shows like that would do
two-parters
uh because exactly yeah you know because
otherwise
every episode stands alone yep exactly
do we ever i guess like batman animated
series would do that sometimes where it
was like
two-parter but then maybe
out of it well i'm just saying that
there's no way that you could
guarantee that the next episode would be
part two
there were
i was going to ask i saw someone in the
comments saying did you play the joker
in the animated series before hamel did
is that true
there was someone saying that in the
comments yeah i was like that doesn't
seem like that
was drunk no i think what they were
saying was that troy would have been
like
15 years old troy played joker at a
younger age than hamill
was joking is what i think 1990
yeah 1990 was when that came out um i
was going to say yeah unless hamill did
it very late and you did it very early
those those
no i think it's just it's just that he's
like he kind of has that old raspy voice
because that's how hamel sounds and then
uh troy i know you did it in origins
and i didn't even realize at first i was
like
what is it different dude what who's
that um
whatever yeah i mean it can't be the
thing that did you know that mark
campbell wasn't the first
i believe yeah jack nicholson
well no on the animated series i think
originally
jack nicholson wasn't even the first
anyway i just can't remember the name of
number one
the guy was attached right who wouldn't
shave it off so it's under the white
material
that's the one yeah um
the first or the first one it was
replaced
a little trivia so it never aired tim
curry
um really way forward to see that
pennywise got him in the door so
there's i can tell the story now because
it's out um
there's kevin conroy gracious inimitable
kind truly heroic kevin conroy
the girl of that scenario the dave girl
and here he is telling this story and
kevin is is a consummate storyteller
and in every way he's got this he's a
broadway
theater trained actor a juilliard
trained actor he's brilliant
and he's telling the stories like
someone said i i understand that
tim curry was originally the original
choice for it for joker
and kevin gracefully tells this story
it's like you know
as in all things there's item we're
iterating upon characters and it's like
king lear you know how do you
do it certain per people are going to be
right for certain things
and he has this wonderfully eloquent way
of
kind of talking around why they went
with somebody else
and then bruce tim goes no he's too
scary he wasn't it was just too scary
just like came straight at it it was
like
what he was like yeah it was too scary
he was like he terrified us
he was just like uh and then you bring
in mark and mark was
that that that show was so wonderfully
cast i mean
ephraim zemballus jr as as alfred
wonderfully
everything yeah everyone fired on all
cylinders
that one and honestly like x-men at the
same time
was just doing [ __ ] there was there's so
many shows that
that um and being able to talk to
um we're doing young justice being able
to talk to them about like gargoyles
and and how that show like that show
went through like five different pitches
to eisner before it finally became a
thing
um and like gummy bears was
really big when they were pitching that
show and so eisner was like we need
another gummy bears they're like
yeah these are gothic
like he's like no i may make him more
gummy bears and so they went around
all these different iterations and they
finally came back to their original
pictures
that's so funny i didn't expect you to
say gummy bears at any point
during any of that gummy bears was the
biggest so for those who have theirs
play watch listen bingo card gummy bears
there was a bouncing here and there and
everywhere
oh yeah dude there was a [ __ ] show of
that uh
oh beautiful this is a lovely book by
the way that is very nice
do you know they were the first can i
show you guys i just got this new batman
and i haven't showed him off let me go
please do it is it more is it more
impressive if i'm playing the forest
[Music]
kind of that was the first
um show to use
they started with black paper as opposed
to white for animation
i think it's true really that's what
gave it
so let me illustrate that let me
illustrate that i can that's not the
cutest man you've ever seen in your life
is that the freezer look at him he's so
chalky
it's kind of like batman by way of brad
bird in uh
that's like tonight right is it like hot
like animated dark knight is it like a
hybrid kind of weird thing
uh i don't think it actually exists in
anything but yes it is
i believe it was called dark knight i'd
have to check though um but it's
supposed to be
an animated series oh that's what troy's
talking about the black paper and then
well so i was gonna say i got the um the
4k
like blu-ray edition when it came out
last year not so long ago
and uh that show still looks beautiful
because of the black
in the background like it just it does
hasn't aged a day it's crazy and then i
also just recently got all the
the lord of the rings um 4k box sets and
i can't
believe the way they've enhanced those
movies when you see side by sides i
don't i just don't even understand how
they've done it
it they they they were washed out and
had these odd
colors before that i never noticed and
when looking at the way that they've
updated them like i genuinely don't know
how that tech works it's absolutely
amazing
they just i think it was like they were
filming that they did a
uh at the um the tlc
tcl sorry the tcl at the man's they did
i think was alan burnett um was there
and talking about
how they did um
let me make sure that was i'm not
misquoting myself yeah alan burnett
um did this amazing thing where
they had started batman animated series
and in order to keep the staff
hired like they so they wouldn't have to
furlough them
they were like what if we just crank
down a movie and so they cranked out
um mask of the phantasm
was that the origins of that that film
was basically just
keeping them going and they did it over
i think they did it in six months or
three months
something insane that's where the best
stuff often comes from is when you're
just messing around riffing in the
corners yeah so wait we were supposed to
have theatrical
it was never it was the first animated
thing the tv the theatrical like that it
was like
it's insane was it not also um one of
those ones that i had
as multiple episodes i remember because
i watched the show as a kid nope it
didn't it
just came out of the actual release no
way you know what's also
what's also so great about that show was
that in
in the era where saturday morning
cartoons
were musically generally all done in the
box
and you can really hear it and as as
amazing as the x-men animated series is
the music
generally does not age well the the what
do you mean by done
how dare you i mean everybody everybody
loves you know
yeah um
done in the box meaning like they're all
samples and they're not
it's all computer it's there's no real
okay i see ikey
software and stark yeah and star and
it's but
but it's generally supposed to sound
like it's real it's one thing to write
electronic music it's another thing to
use fake strings
and bat the the x-men show is
unfortunately
it just sounds like what the best of
tech was
in the you know early 90s uh
in contrast batman the animated series
was a full
live orchestra every single episode
um they pulled out all the stops and the
cool thing was that it was done by
shirley
walker who um was she had conducted
and orchestrated the movie score of
danny elfman's
and so it was like kind of like you know
take his theme and then go off and do
your own thing
and um she already said good
well she already has the the the sort of
um trivia of being the first woman to
ever score a major hollywood studio film
but it's her tv which was the movie
memoirs of the invisible man
but but her tv work is considered like
because of specifically the batman
animated series and also she did
she wrote she scored mask of the
phantasm
and a bunch of others um she
she's one of those like iconic everybody
just holds her up
uh as you know the benchmark of what tv
especially
the so-called you know um
how would you phrase it the world of
saturday morning cartoons is not where
people look to for their high art
uh in the amongst the you know the the
snobby emmy voters who are looking for
their
you know their breaking bads uh and
assuming that's where all the best stuff
is going to be found she she's
represents one of those like hold on
let me show you just what we can do here
this only
occurred to me really recently actually
upon watching um detective pikachu that
you can have
content that is for children that
doesn't
have to be dumbed down for kids so
uh like i feel like that's that's the
philosophy of pixar isn't it like top to
bottom
oh isn't it that but that's that's
iterating off of bugs money like that's
that's looney tunes
because they were hitting on two levels
like if you go back and watch
bugs bunny cartoons and they're like the
the
uh king arthur episode or whatever
they're going around they're they're
listing all the different
um let's swap it around like that's
great i i just froze so i was like i was
fixing it's fine i'm
carrying moving forward too late um
the there's two things i want to comment
on
first of all the the bugs bunny thing is
like they would do stuff like
uh sir loin of beef cirrhosis of liver
that's not for kids that's for the
adults watching because
by and large those were being presented
before a movie was being played at a
theater
that's when you watched your cartoons
there was no saturday morning cartoons
up until late 50s early 60s
when all of a sudden it was um howdy
duty time and
and that kind of ushered in this new era
of of television but i think what made
the leap from saturday
saturday morning cartoons were were x
and that was a genre
but that's not what batman animated
series was that was
after school and that's a huge
distinction
not just you're right not just after
school but like right before
adult tv came on so it was this bridging
the gap because you had like the the
disney hour
which was like started off with chip and
dale's rescue rangers and then duck
tales
and so you would like from like 3 to 4
30 was like this
rad defining epic era of television
and the weirdest one was teenage mutant
ninja
turtles started on sunday night that's
when it first aired it wasn't an
afternoon or a saturday morning cartoon
it was
prime time sunday night it came on like
after mary with children
and it was this fledgling network
you know that ended up becoming um i
wonder if they did that because it was
an existing property that was already
popular before it became a tv no it
wasn't though it was a black and white
graphic novel that yeah
didn't they already have the toys before
they had the tv show oh
no all of a sudden they were like [ __ ]
it we're gonna do this like i think it
was a mini series and i wish i could
talk to uh we may sold it in
simultaneously i think the toys in the
show was like well that's why they made
the show was to sell the toys
yeah always same thing with gi joe same
thing with
my little pony i think it's pretty
he-man is
all transformers let's sleep yeah
it's can we just comment on the fact
that alana's had the word poo
above her head now for like 20 minutes
and ho and ho poo and ho
yeah i just love you
what i was actually going to say with
that point was paddington i feel like is
such a good example of a movie that
is i think pretty much unironically
perfect
paddington one and two uh two of the
best films i have ever seen
uh really yes i thought people were
joking when they said that no
no it's they're beautiful they're
beautiful family films i think that's
the difference between
like the looney tunes because the looney
tunes model feels like nowadays that's
kind of the dreamworks thing right where
you're putting in the jokes for the mom
and dad and but also you're
you're you're doing the kids stuff
paddington i think is
and and i think this is true of like the
lego movie as well and a few other films
like there are movies where the kid and
the adult are watching the same movie
but they're enjoying it like for and
this is i guess true of pixar as well
but like it's not when you're watching
paddington there's no jokes in
paddington that are like
hey hey you you know about these adult
things it's like you double up
along for the story yeah it's fat it's
family it's it's you're both watching
and enjoying the same film but it just
it's not speaking down to the kids so
that like an adult actually enjoys it
is lovely which is my issue with
detective pikachu is
they would tell you what had happened
show you a flashback of it happening and
then
zoom in on something to try to sell the
plot to kids
and as someone who was very excited to
see that movie i had this
this thought around that movie coming
out of how unnecessary that was
and then if the kids don't care about
the plot they don't need to they care
about the giant pokemon
you don't have to try and sell it to
kids you can have a smart plot that
doesn't have to be like
see kid make sure you you get this point
they just don't need it
but games do the same thing so where
does that come from
like mistrust it's mistrust of the
audience it's and and
ultimately mistrust of yourself okay
games do it because players actually
miss it like the games do they're like
here you have to look at this because
you've seen a camera if you've ever if
you've ever been playing the game and
you've
and you've you've gone to a room and
you're like oh i have to go over there
and there's
a camera has come in in slo-mo and
pointed out the place you're going
that is because a bunch of game
designers had to watch
50 percent of the audience not see that
door it's great that you did
but like the the there is nothing more
nerve-wracking than being in the room
for play tests and seeing
someone run around in circles not being
able to find the door
and and yeah there are subtle brilliant
artistic ways of doing that if you've
got time
you can do all of the clever stuff with
lights that's my question though
so isn't it but that takes time and
money you know that takes effort and
there's and it's often easier just to
put in the camera case of just going
but that's okay so but that's you owning
the fact that that it is a cheat
oh ev every i mean with with if very few
game designers and game developers in
general get to work
with infinite resources of time money
arguably none do but obviously
some people have higher ceilings than
others so yeah no
i'm i remember visiting um is that a
segway to cyberpunk
i think this is all yeah this is all
stuff that's out there so we're visiting
naughty dog and kind of
getting the tour of how they do their
stuff and naughty dog they
make some games everybody knows about
uncharted shelter
but they but but their their play
testing methodology is phenomenal like
their their play testing process the the
way that's all set up i can't remember
which bits of it are public and which on
so i'll keep my mouth shut but like
looking at them and seeing the amount of
energy and effort they get to go
and also how early in the process it
happens they can actually adjust things
and kind of improve stuff
you know on the indie side we don't
necessarily have all of those resources
we still do play testing it's very
important but you're often yeah you're
up against it you've got
if you've got a couple of months and you
know no one's understanding how to get
to the end of level three you've got to
make the choice that's going to get them
there you know and and it's not always
there it's not always
the glamorous perfect case because you
know there's this puzzle which is a
better move though
which is a better let's say you're doing
ten levels and
you can either like that's your goal to
do ten levels
is it better to go let's just cheat and
get from level three to level four
or is it go we actually need to reduce
and and no one will ever know that there
was supposed to be ten levels
seven i've done both i've removed
that seems to be the better thing it's
like let's make it better design
because i can always cheat but like
here's here's the like as a parent right
now
i think it's a case-by-case basis right
like i just wanted to mention there's
this puzzle in the first dark side is it
when i visited gunfire i was making a
mini dock about
a game they were working on and
there's this one puzzle only one if i
remember correctly
they often have like pans around the
environment but that would draw you into
what you were looking at because
they tried having like tracks on the
ground that would make your eye line go
to it
they tried making it shiny putting this
little like white thing on it that's
still on it
and people would still miss it they were
like we had to just like pull people
into it because otherwise no matter
what else we did in the level that we
would think would draw your eye line
there
people just didn't see it okay but like
perfect example
we're going on a walk the other day with
traveler
and he is at this point right now where
he
he's learned i need help which is great
i want him to ask for our help
but what he's doing is like you meant he
learned that you need help
[Laughter]
he like dropped a car because i pick up
the car
and he starts losing it and what we
would call nuclear which means he's just
crying
and i was like pick it up dude it's like
and we were just kidding
yeah we stabbed we stood there for five
minutes and he's like i need help i was
like buddy we're right here
we're right here but you can pick that
up i want you to bend down i want you to
pick that up
and any other parent i know and we're
outside and it's just like but i can't
he's like losing his [ __ ] and finally
he picked he bent down and he picked it
up and he was totally fine
the cheat would be [ __ ] it let's just
pick up the car give it to him
and move on but it's more important for
me to spend those five minutes
as uncle uncomfortable as it is and
people passing by looking at this like
side eye and it's like we're bad parents
it's like no we're being great
you would have to teach a kid that
lesson
yeah of course you do the thing that's
why everything is programming
so i think so much stuff that's inherent
like eating but [ __ ] but
honestly going picking up food and
putting it in your mouth is a learned
thing
it's not inherent i think the takeaway
from this is that troy regards gamers as
screaming children
kind of well it's worse they're they're
they're screaming adults who've paid you
like and that's the i think that's i
think it's really it's really
like it's valid like what you're saying
about obviously obviously that's the
right way to raise a kid but like
if someone's giving me their time if
someone's like you know they've given me
some money they've given
they've they're you know playing for an
hour after work and they're they just
want to get to the fun
you know it's tricky where i think we're
making great strides as a medium right
now is with the accessibility
conversations because i wouldn't think
what that does
and we're we're hitting all the big
normal topics of the show right now what
that does
is i think people when they hear about
accessibility they you jump to the
assumption that accessibility isn't for
me it's for people with disabilities
it's for people who
who have more specific kind of barriers
to entry
but no we all have like areas of areas
where we're better and worse at playing
or where
or or different just in terms of like
not understanding it's not picking up
stuff
every every game you're playing is
actually making a lot of
um affordances for you as a player
anyway right because
in real life none of us would walk into
a room and take out four bad guys
troy might i think troy's up to it he's
got yeah
it's a true story the first time i met
chad who's the director of the john wick
uh movies he uh someone
one of the producers was asking him like
how he sets up a fight scene
and schedules he's like i'll tell you
right now you work out who the biggest
dangers are and you work your way
and he points at me and he says i'd take
him out last because he'd be the least
trouble
and i was like chad we're going to get
on very well
um but no sir but like like what i'm
saying is all games give you affordances
aim assist
is a brilliant example of this if you've
shot a gay if you've shot a gun in a
console game
you the computer was helping you we're
gonna move past it we're gonna move past
it we're gonna move faster
what was the phrase i'm you're being
very generous was the mic
please do is that what is that what i
said because i cut myself off
you're the best father
yes it's crazy unfortunate
i'm going to finish the point though
carry on like it is because it but it is
like
when you shoot no no it's bad it's bad
um
basically if you've played a game you've
you've been helped and to some extent or
another you're you know if you're
playing call of duty you are gay game
assist
even if you switch it off there is some
level of helping that's always going on
so therefore what's great about the
accessibility conversation is if we
normalize the idea of being able to
change those settings and tailor
experiences
i don't have to hit such a wide target
if i know that troy does
if i know that troy hates the camera
that tells him where to go
i can make it an option to toggle that
off and that's going to make troy's time
better with the game
it's going to make my life easier
because troy's not going to be
complaining about it but removing it is
bad for people with adhd for example
among them exactly so when you're so
often you're trying to hit the big
target of like i have a game i have four
difficulty levels i need to make sure
that 80
of our audience gets to the end on the
difficulty level they are if they want
to and i need to cater to that
the more we can kind of make that
granular the better and the more we can
give you the experience you want
i am going to bring up what everybody
what everybody always punts to
inside okay since we all can agree
that's a perfect game
um i love it
so much i think it's a perfect game i
have to
the the real sex doll collectization
thing on my
coffee table and i left it there while i
got my apartment cleaned recently and i
was like what do you think she thinks of
me
what do you think she thinks this
[ __ ] blob thing is
but i was like i'm gonna leave it out
deep advertising clean it that's the
question
you're only allowed to clean it with
water they're very specific about how
you clean your real sex toys which is
apparently
why i didn't clean i didn't clean the
thing
my thing is oh my god an interesting
article
i feel like what they did was focused
was program
long ago was progress the medium in such
a way that said
we're going back to the way the games
were their true retro game in the sense
what that was
either you go out and you buy the guide
or you just sit here and grind and
figure it out
as opposed to tutorialization and a
hud in all of which way do you move what
which which
which how many dimensions can you move
in and inside
absolutely totally which direct which
direction do you move in
i also i think well i think you you are
it's always going left to right not
giving inside enough credit
in that i agree it doesn't tell you
anything and i love that that's why i
love the witness
it's like here's a puzzle [ __ ] figure
them all out from here i love that about
it
it's antagonistic it is
you better remember if you put it down
for six months son i don't
there's there's a lot of games that do
that even even the room did inside
the use of lighting is very and sound
both
very very very specific to lead you in
the right direction it's just not text
on the screen
but it's still leading you in the right
way at all times that's designed that's
what i'm saying it's not it's it's
waiting for the kid
to and not putting the clock on it with
the exception of
um there are certain times like the dogs
come after you or whatever
but it's it's it's it's a very patient
game and it's a very but i i i can't
help i would love to sit down and do a
deep dive with them
i love that game as to how much they
scoped
you know what i mean i think it's i
think it's i think it's i i would
my gut has always been given how long
they worked on it that it was about
polish more than about scope that
every single pixel is like
perfectly carefully chosen and very
deliberate there's
there every single puzzle every
challenge is like
really carefully sort of
manicured to perfection so that it feels
like we are
doing what alana's describing which i
think is totally accurate
the game the game gives you exactly what
you need
and nothing more um but it's also not
it's not opaque ever to me yeah i never
got stuck on that game right like it's
not
and i think that's the thing i'm not
belittling it i'm not i'm not i'm trying
not to i'm not being dismissive of it
because i don't think it i think
it's an excellent game but they are they
are making choices about affordance as
well
they are they are limiting the actions
that it would occur to you to take
and because of that that does mean they
can funnel you towards stuff
much more easily and then do it
beautifully with a lot of polish but
there is
even they're making choices there is a
reason they consciously
did not make that game a 3d game okay i
just wanted to confirm
pretty sure i put it in my my list of my
top five
last generation games and i did
does that mean that you think that the
game subtly
sort of cheating to help the player is
bad design because the design
i don't think player that that's that's
a reduction
a reductionist view i don't believe it's
bad design what i do believe is
it is the same thing as me as a parent
making a choice to pick up the car for
traveler
i can either is a perfect example i'm in
here doing a session
and there's a someone the same almost
literally the same instance
traveler is wanting to pick up another
car or he's wanting to stand up and he
feels like he can't do it
pam is is in other part of the house but
travelers having this moment
and i walked in there i was like just to
let you know
i'm working and where it's this is not a
teaching moment
so there's another reason why the exact
same response is not the appropriate one
so i get it sometimes you're like yes if
we could do that we absolutely would but
what mike's saying is like we have
publisher demands
we have limited budget we have limited
time we have limited staff
if we if other things were in play then
we would absolutely sit time and iterate
and polish polish polish manicure but we
can't do that on this level
because we've got to get past level
three so i i i'm not saying
yours is definitely the perfect version
like i would i would i would if
in in a perfect world i would i would
aim to do it because i actually think
you're
i think i think you're being uh
potentially a little
um generous in the i think i think the
designer who brilliantly places a light
to guide you to the exit
is still picking up the toy for the kid
like they're still
directing you they're just doing it with
much more subtlety and elegance
than me bluntly making camera it's the
same thing leaving
leaving the kids pick up the toy
themselves would be to do none of these
things
so to me it's just it's a much better
more finessed
more polished approach to the same
problem
when i when i think it's bad design is
when i'm sitting in the booth
not on the stage i mean sometimes it's
been on the stage and there have been
multiple examples of that but in the
booth
and basically we're going full
diegetic fixed design and go well maybe
you should
pick up the try the door troy what
you're talking about is my number one
beef with alan wake this ongoing beef i
have with alan wake when you enter a
level alan goes
oh i hate my wife i guess i better get
to that ladder
and then the camera pulls you into the
ladder and then it like again reminds
you
you have to get there alan said you have
to get there this is where you have to
go and i'm like [ __ ] off
alan there was even stuff in bioshock
where i didn't do that i was like i
wonder what i should do and booker would
literally say what are we gonna do and
then
bank i mean loud like rip your
headphones off
go to the next town there's just like
there's no agency that you have in that
and whenever if something appears on
screen
man it better to me it better be
aesthetic
it better be diegetic it better be
anything other than
i don't want to see a i don't like a hud
if if it's practical like if i'm playing
call of duty or something i want to see
what my weapon loadout is and what all
of that [ __ ] great
but if i could operate without a map
awesome i don't want to see
exactly the perfect example i was
talking to gary wood about that
yesterday
and he was like man this is the this is
the kind of game that i really want to
play
where it's just like oh nice i saw that
he he was playing it on ios too
yeah and everyone was like don't play it
like that i'm [ __ ]
i can't wait i've got it on pc and i've
got it on ios
i the thing that i love about a game
like that where it is you look at
cyberpunk and it's like i love big
worlds
200 hours of gameplay yeah but cyberpunk
in the first
20 in the first 20 minutes the sheer
amount of tutorial
of like you got to learn this and this
and this and this and this i was so
quickly like
holy [ __ ] this is this is it has a lot
of systems
a lot of systems but i will say one
thing that i'm loving about
cyberpunk and i'm trying not to talk
about the game editorially i said like
i'm not going to give many opinions on
this game but
um why i've oh because i worked on it
technically
like i'm in the credits it's like i'm
trying to talk about the stuff that i
worked on all the time
people get pretty upset so i was just
like i'm just gonna not do it um but
i've learned the city quite well uh
there are street names that are visible
everywhere
there are districts that are really
defined and i think one of the cooler
things about night city which is still
my favorite part of the game
is being able to in theory be like oh i
was in this area you know the one where
the shopping center has like the several
ramps that lead into it and it goes high
and people say oh yeah
you can talk about it like it's a real
city it's uh and again i love street
names and i love that about like daisy
like
games like that where you can actually
try and figure out where you are based
on like well here's this landmark and
here's this thing and you don't need to
cta was rudimentary like that too like
you could do
that in in gta easier because it's based
on an actual real city like
so night city is la inspired but
well i can be like come at the airport
yeah one thing about watchdog's legion
is if you've lived in london you know
exactly where everything is it's weird
see you say that
a test we did a test where we did uh
assassin's creed
um unity say oh my god
just
[Laughter]
great music we're just talking about the
pathless austin you get one game per
shot
[Music]
troy has broken that rule many times
yeah you're right yes
you mentioned origins we've been through
naughty dog
granted i don't know it's which is
harder to talk about games that austin's
done
the game's lifetime you cover a lot of
you let's be real
got me you've got me thoroughly beaten
there but we did
we paired that up with with uh watchdogs
legion
because it was both you know syndicated
for the record i was saying it
syndicate and and uh legion are both you
know supposed to be one to one you could
also do getaway too which was the first
one to do that time
the getaway is properly one to one to a
full like the giveaway is actual
yeah so like what they were ps3 right
they were early ps3
ps2 ps2 holy [ __ ] yes two on getaway
getaway was like actually like perfect
to london but therefore was not
necessarily a great game space
lee uh watch those agents definitely
like compressed like there's definitely
streets missing annoyingly the street i
lived on is missing which is really
annoying i did a stream with ronaldo and
had him try to show me around the city
and he was [ __ ] useless like he did
not know yeah it's pretty to be fair
to you if you if you're a londoner who
travels by tube everywhere like that's
what he said
he was like we don't walk around london
so that was the difference between me
like
i took victoria atkin up on the top of
basically uh westminster abbey and i was
like okay so
if we're doing here we need to go left
she's like no i think we need to go
right it's like the river's right in
front of us
we need to go left left is going east
she goes no i think right it's like
what are you talking about don't let her
accent fool you man she's living
it is the difference between like
someone who is a londoner or whatever
they're like
we're never above ground yeah i play
that game where they go
underground it was a good two or three
years i'd been living there before i for
whatever reason decided to just walk
from one place to another
and you and you're walking like all of
these places that in your brain you've
mentally mapped as like little hub
worlds that they're just next to each
other it's like weird kind of
thought process it is funny i had to i
had i had that exact experience living
in manhattan
uh where different subway stop
destinations where you're like oh if i'm
going to the you know to the
to the um the new york public library
versus central park they're like five
minutes walk from each other
but they're different stops uh well no
but that's the thing
and i mean the park is an un reasonable
example because it's like a third of the
island but
right but there's 20 different stops
that hit it but
but nonetheless that point of
experiencing the walk from one
destination above ground to another that
you associate as being different stops
because your mind just categorizes as
like
i may as well be going light speed
between stations
they're like thousands of light years
apart from each other
and they're discreet right they're
completely part of each other
central park goes from 59th to it's
really 81st
way above 80. and it was the stupidest
decision we ever made was to walk the
length of central park
no you don't even know i've done that a
couple of times because i like no it's
amazing
yeah it's beautiful no it's oh it's it's
awesome but like we thought it was going
to be like the size of like saint john's
park in the uk
james park st james park is not even
like i
i did one of my favorite runs that i've
ever done in london
i come out of um the
royal horse guards hotel walk through
the royal horse guard stable
and do the run from st james park which
is a beautiful park that backs up into
buckingham palace
and then i came around and there was
this one song that i had on my playlist
um and as it's like the whole world
for the queen her fascist unless you
went past yeah it's absolutely
exactly what it was um it's a i can't
play for you guys because we'll get
[ __ ] shut down appreciate that um
actually i don't care you can if you
like that already happened because me
and allah did such a good job that's
true
anybody should check it out it's indie
artist mondo cosmo cozymo and the song
is called shine
and it's just this great just feel good
song and as i'm coming out of st james
park
the royal horse guards are right across
ring which is the royal stables
and it's the changing if you've ever
been in london you've seen the changing
of the guard that's one thing that's
what everybody goes but what you really
want to see is the changing of the horse
guard
because they parade these like 20
i mean incredible huge horses
and they're doing the change in the
garden and these guys are coming down
and they're just clopping parading down
the street
and as i'm coming around the song just
like crescendos and then just i
get chills thinking about it right now
one of the guys just looks down at me
just goes
and i went and i just burst down and
then you let the parade right
you left and i led the parade the queen
was like ew
and i like took a left around and then i
came around to falgore square and there
was doves everywhere like i'm in a john
woo
movie it was awesome it's one of my
favorite moments in london ever well we
are like all over the place i gotta say
i know i'm like how the [ __ ] am i gonna
title this one i know i said that a lot
batman yeah i did want to say i did
actually to make sure so because it
seemed so eclectic uh
i wanted to google the the name of this
beautiful toy that i have shown because
i love him
um the sex toy oh sorry the inside sex
toy
uh it's batman the adventures of the
adventures continue super i'm a batman
action figure and it is
we're correct based on the animated
series but also the dark knight
um which i think is really cool well
done because they did that episode
they did an episode of animated series
where they did the dark knight in the
animated series style right that was uh
yeah
did they what was it that is not based
on that though i don't think
no this i've got this weird memory of
like a batman animated version of dark
knight and i i don't know if it was like
part of a noun
well there's a person where he's beefier
like that i can distinctly remember but
i mean literally just like with the sky
guys
and the tank where are you talking about
batman beyond
no i'm thinking of like i'm literally
thinking of like
of bruce tim doing
i mean i i'm gonna have to look this up
i've seen this i have memories of you
know the tank scene with all the
um with all the what they call this the
bad guy the cyborg guys from uh
dark knight no no dog yeah dog now
returns
me i'm gonna look it up i'm gonna look
it up okay well i'm gonna enjoy the show
hi everyone welcome to play watch listen
i'm a video game writer that's austin
he's a video game composer that's
[ __ ] troy he's a video game actor and
that's mike bethel he is a video game
director
is there austin is god damn it [ __ ]
yeah
she's good content make sure you got to
get it right troy you're not even
getting it right when you're getting it
right justin mike
me wait you're on the bottom
i'm on the top right next okay that's
what i thought i didn't think it ever
puts anyone in the bottom of their own
screen right
yes there is an episode called legends
of the dark knight which is an anthology
episode of the batman animated show
where they did that scene from dark
knight
there you go legends of the dark knight
so i really did want to talk about
cyberpunk
um but i really really did yeah and to
answer
to answer your question which i realized
i never did
i um
i didn't want to play it on my
pc gaming rig that i have here in the
studio because i wanted to play
at night so angela and i could kind of
tag team
but i still have not been able to get a
hold of a ps5 so i was like ah [ __ ] it
i'm just getting it on ps4 let's just
embrace
the bug mania and um look at this face
it's it's definitely everything
everyone's complaining about that is
really uh can i ask a question yeah
ign
giving it before it's more state of mind
okay the console version yeah
for that because they said i think a lot
of you posted this i think your your
your caption was yikes i said holy [ __ ]
because
they rarely do that because
it felt to me a bit of a petulant
um score to go you did bad because it
didn't play well in this
is a console is is a game
responsible for the console's
faults oh we should have started with
this now during the podcast
you ever reach a point in the podcast
where you're like i'm going to be
reading a transcription of the next
three sentences
[Laughter]
so again troy um this isn't
a score for cyberpunk it's a score for
consumers which is why
their note says please don't play
cyberpunk 2077 on a base xbox one or ps4
they are saying
bad to let players know it is bad on
this hardware
and i looked up i have this video from
two three years ago
where i was sure that i said it and uh
it was
interesting to find it where i go
there's no way that this is gonna run on
current gen hardware there's just
absolutely no way
um and it i guess it doesn't very well
but
the the main point even surrounding all
of that and i say this is someone who's
playing on pc with the 3080 and is
having an incredible experience like i
find the game
to be like consistently breathtaking i'm
like holy [ __ ] this is beautiful
um very different to what console
players are having if they
sold the game on those platforms made it
available for purchase on those
platforms
and it doesn't function on those
platforms it is their fault
yeah that is something that they have to
take accountability for i'm
completely inclined to agree if i were
to release if i were to
bend over backwards to make the greatest
surround
sound album of all time
and then release it you know
on on something that can play back on a
normal
stereo channel cd player and but having
sold it on
its surround sound and but everybody's
hardware is playing it back and just
auto algorithmically squashing it down
to stereo
that's on me as the producer like that's
definitely not
faulting them for having the wrong
equipment but does that not mean that
what has to happen is as they're deving
i don't know i don't know if like the
dev kits for a ps4 are gonna
operate differently so you can't really
one to one compare but as
as your qa people are going through and
go i've got a bug i've got a bug i've
got a bug i've got a bug
that means that they have to they would
be they would essentially
have to be the most vile
you know i mean i mean mcavailian
level to go we're just going to flat out
steal people's money
or is it i don't think that was their
intent i don't think it's their intent i
i can't imagine
so either they didn't know they were
told that it would work
and that it and then it didn't or it was
a mitigating your loss going
people are going to have i think what
happened here is
such an interesting example of
the conversation surrounding like
consoles hold games back
um that cdpr
didn't let that happen that that
basically what
they've done is released something that
on a high-end pc
you know not people can't even get 3080s
like i know that what i'm playing is
is not the standard um this game is is
beautiful and and functions very well i
have had crashes but it was due to to do
with the
gog overlay as soon as i turned that off
they stopped weirdly
oh that's uh cdpr's like own storefront
effectively it's their steam
they probably would have tested it with
gog i would have thought you'd think
it's weird the minute i turned it off it
stopped happening really strange uh
that's why and i know a lot of people
had that problem it's odd but um
that they they made a game that in
theory
as time goes on people will continue to
have a better experience with it
which is not the way you usually release
a game uh instead
of racist level that's christmas i was
gonna bring up christ
it is like instead of like taking bits
out
uh so that the xbox one and ps4 players
have a good game but then everyone else
for a longer amount of time also has to
have a lesser experience and i'm not
saying i agree with this i think that
what they've done here is
is bad when so many of the pre-orders
are on uh
these old consoles but it is it is a
very interesting thing to have happen is
it's not that they neglected
dev on those consoles it's not that they
didn't try and i'm
certain that they didn't want it to come
out this way it was not well [ __ ]
let's just steal that money
idiots are just going to buy a new
version anyway it's just a
game too big game can't run [ __ ] um
well my guess if i had to if i had to
wager and i
i um i really have no idea this is pure
speculation
but my guess is that they
underestimated the shortage of next-gen
consoles that would have greeted their
release
because i think sure but it's not
connection
yet anyway because the version that you
currently are playing on next-gen
consoles is just the old version they
haven't had the updated version on those
consoles
oh i didn't know are the bugs mitigated
when when playing via emulation on the
next gen consoles are people having a
better time with it on ps5
look i feel like i've probably seen
more screenshots of this game than most
people because anyone who's finding me
in the game is then sending me their
version of it so like
hundreds of them all day every day
constantly seeing different versions of
this game
and as far as i can tell from what
people are telling me
it is running better on the series x um
than it is on
on preview and this is super anecdotal
of course is just based on these people
who send me the screenshots um
but i don't entirely it's it's it is
still the same game it's just that
you know the the frame rate is not as
bad and i haven't had really any visible
frame rate drops playing on pc so it's
better but it's still not expected to
run
yeah you wouldn't expect it to run any
differently so the bugs would still be
present bugs are stupid
it's interesting i mean the reality is
and i feel like
it always feels like you're an apologist
when you say this but it's true is
you've never played a video game
that didn't have bugs in it like every
video game ships with bugs inevitably
and the the challenge to developing a
game is always to
decide on the prioritization of okay
which bugs are we okay with
which bugs do we have to fix you know
and what
what level of of that we're going to do
because if you always presume that's
it's the reason that like you always
there's never going to be a game that's
released that you can't find like a
youtube video of someone getting a weird
stupid bug
because if it's a one in 10 000 bug
then similar problem with reviews that's
really interesting bugs are so
subjective that i remember when
microsoft flight simulator came out and
was getting tens i was like how this
game crashes on me all the time
how are you giving it tens and so i
reached out to someone who was like i
don't understand
like this game crashes and i never had a
crash you're like oh
well for you it is a 10 out of 10. for
me it's got to be like seven
like it just it's so subjective
it's a sliding scale and when you're a
developer you are making that choice and
and all this reads like to me and again
like austin like i have no
knowledge so it could be absolute
nonsense but my presumption is they
you usually as a dev team know the bugs
there's especially when you've got a big
qa process which i'm sure they have
they would have known that these bugs
were there but they'll have made the
decision that they didn't think they
would
massively impact people's experience and
clearly the audience disagrees with them
on that
but i would say that's the case there
are bugs there and none of them matter
enough that
anything and that's the truth it's the
truth
right it's it's the thing that that
edward nord talks about is like if the
cost of a recall
is more than yeah the payout we don't do
one it was like
that makes sense and i think i feel like
i feel like in these situations
in these situations the qa team always
gets the blame like why how did you not
find these bugs the qa team found these
bugs probably
yeah they said all the time i wish they
had to delete it
it's a production right already the
developers
the qa guys will have known about this
and they'll found it they'll have done
their jobs
the developers if i'm sure if they had
unlimited time in resources they would
have been able to fix them of course
ultimately this comes down to someone
and probably several someone's given the
scale of the production
looking at a spreadsheet and going we
can we can ship with those
that's okay
judgment on that but that will have been
having been in that situation several
times like that will have been the
process and
yeah god knows have bugs in them that
hopefully
no one will ever find well and you have
to factor also a game of this scale
like as your game gets bigger those expo
there's a there's like a very very
exponential rise in how
bugs can can happen like a very system
driven open world game is such a
vastly different level of complexity of
the way things interact
i know that in my case even on a game
like pathless
which is so much smaller by comparison
but structurally kind of similar in that
it's also an open world game
as a member of the team you know i can
submit bug reports as i
find them in the game and every now and
again i'll find a graphics bug and i
think uh you know maybe
i have a novel one and if i don't submit
it no one else will have found it
so i'll submit those even though
normally what i'm looking for is just
audio and music bugs
um and it's
one of the first things i ask you which
people don't realize
when especially if just blaming a qa
department
is that the the one of the things your
responsibility is
in submitting a bug report at least in
my experience
is to uh list out the reproduction
steps so that someone else can recreate
yeah the repro of a of a
bug and sometimes that's freaking hard
especially on an open world game because
you're like
it could have been that i had this
inventory item and then i went into this
area and then i did this one
and this super esoteric series of events
made
that car load you know without texting
you might not even
make an assumption about the wrong one
yeah you'll invent a rain dance like
which i don't know maybe that's maybe
that's a dated way of phrasing it but
like you'll invent this
you'll you'll be like no i'm pretty sure
it's when i'm wearing this particular
shoe the game breaks
and it'll become something completely
different to that but you'll you'll
build these little narratives all these
things so complicated just it's really
hard
unsung heroes dude every time i go to a
studio
i always make sure i swing by so many of
them are full time
so many studios as well these are people
who just like work tirelessly to repeat
things over and over again
as a contractor and then get laid
when you think that qa is overwhelmingly
populated by people where that's their
entry into the game industry where
they're like here's how i'm gonna break
in
and it's like let's make you hate games
yeah uh because it just puts you through
the first step to making them oh austin
that's the first step well i know that
there are qa departments where uh and i
think this was ea
um it would have been in the 90s but
they had this leaderboard for how
long each person had stayed in the
office for and if you were the top of
the leaderboard you'd get like a prize
for that month
where if you had filled in the most time
of not leaving the [ __ ] office they
give you like
wine or something like holy [ __ ] what a
super
healthy way to make games awful
the one thing the one thing i think
backs up your theory of honor about kind
of the kind of the future focus for them
from what i've said most of the stuff
i've seen seems to be bugs related to
streaming
or like data streaming so like like low
things not loading correctly
a weird low poly version of a character
appearing yeah
that i think is only on the older
consoles i've not heard any of that the
most common that's what i'm saying is
like something that would be oh sorry
the only the most common bug that i've
gotten is and it's still not frequent i
did have one
uh quest that i had to reload because it
thought that i hadn't done an objective
that i had
um but otherwise it's just things
floating so occasionally just like
i had like a traffic light floating
i've seen a lot of screenshots of
characters loading in t-pose also
i have not had any t-shirts not one and
i want to see myself in t-posts
[Laughter]
when i hear about loading issues i do
start to feel like maybe there are that
the plan was next gen and like this has
maybe
been a result that because a lot of
those kind of bugs would be done
would be less of a problem basically on
like next-gen hardware so
supposedly people playing on stadia
because of the way that that
works they're having a really good time
and it's like very because that's pc
they're playing presumably they're
playing like basically they are
streaming from a pc yeah
so that that's a really interesting case
of like well maybe console players
should
try it on stadium if it's a game
[Laughter]
no no it's just noticeably not
um polished it's jus it it feels
weirdly last-gen um
like the last like the last of us part
two
actively looks better at any given
moment that's the thing that keeps
getting me about so much of this if you
look at red dead redemption 2
and it's not ugly it just feels like you
have if you put cyberpunk next to red
dead redemption 2 on the same platform
you're like look at red dead look at how
good that game is
open world i didn't have [ __ ] floating
but it's just a completely different
development cycle like
it's the scale of it like it seems like
from what i've seen of some people
playing on
xbox the screenshot ign used of that
that character who's not loaded in it
feels like i am playing a completely
different game
which sucks so bad and that's why like
i'm not gonna like rant about how good
my experience is when in reality is most
people can't have my experience you
can't even get
the newer consoles if you were planning
to play it that way because they're all
sold out
and you know even getting pc hardware
the 38 game the 90 are sold out too
it's just it's so it's so restrictive
for most people in a way that really
really sucks
but i can't really know the ratio i'd
love to know what percentage of players
are playing
on those last gen consoles so most
pre-orders for this game were on pc
um which i thought was interesting yeah
majority of their pre-orders with pc and
obviously it's a pc focused company in
that you know they have
gog that's where they want people to buy
the thing that's it's they make all the
money from it so of course they want
people to make all the money from there
yeah
yeah um is it is it a different version
of the stupid question but just so i
understand is it
is it a different version if you bought
it on steam versus if you bought it on
their store yeah
you just get some like you played it
but that's it there'd be some api kind
of hookups that would be different
in the same way as like when we sell the
game on wednesday
api is application i've never actually
had to work out what the
what the acronym is it's all it's the
alpha our
application protocol
it's an interface so it's it's if
steam's over here
and my game's over here it's the stuff
that makes those two things talk
together it says
it's a computer interface that defines
interactions between multiple software
intermediaries it defines the kinds of
calls or requests that can be made how
to make them the data formats that
should be used the conventions to follow
you're so interesting yeah i i i'm
telling you i didn't read that that's
amazing this is off the top of your head
i've been a game dev for a month mike
watch yourself you just pick this [ __ ]
up
when you when you get an achievement
troy in a game the game
says troy's got an achievement it yells
at steam or xbox or whatever and then
they're listening and they say oh yep
you've got an achievement that's an api
call that's just that's
the relationship between the two the big
so the it's the connective tissue
just like some places if you get trophy
unlocked that's going to be that's api
that's the platform
the game telling the platform to give
you so the playstation speaks french
steam speaks german gog speaks russian
and i have tried to yell different
things to each of those platforms to
make them understand it's so funny that
that you got all of those wrong wouldn't
it be that gog speaks polish
playstations
it was super interesting but uh for all
intents and pups is i think it's the
same version but with pcs obviously
again it depends on what kind of
hardware you have and that's the
weirdest thing is like i'm not gonna
recommend that anyone plays this game
because all i can speak to is my own
experience and with this game it's so
subjective like and i know how
subjective it is and it's just it's so
unique like i don't
i can't think of another game launch
that's been like this um
and of course the cyberpunk launch was
always going to be a big deal and it's
this gross thing that i think we've got
in video game discourse at this point
where you can see from a mile off the
culture wars coming
like we knew even before it happened
that the last of us part two was going
to rip people apart
before we had any leaks it was like
people are gonna take i remember
i remember when we were having private
conversations the conversation about
last of us
i've not played it yet no i'm waiting
that's confused
the uh i'm waiting for the ps5 uh remix
um no the uh the like i remember when we
were having i remember like private
conversations before that game came out
the vibe among everyone was this one's
going to be a trip like there's going to
be a lot of conversation it's going to
be
positive and negative there's going to
be this is going to be a conversation
starter
cyberpunk is the same like no matter
what if it launched perfectly it was the
same and i feel like it's just
become this thing where we attach
ourselves i don't
know the we is the right phrase but uh
people attach themselves to properties
and they're either going to hate it or
they're going to love it and they know
that before it even happens
and then the game comes out and has
issues and they're happy or it comes out
and it's
people like it and they feel validated
and it's just weird just like very
strong identities tied to brands that
that just create this
war that i think makes it kind of lost
to do that
that's what it that's why i is
we go back and we let them have the
moment
where we stand out to the side as the
industry and say if it takes five
minutes or ten minutes we're gonna let
them pick up the car
but to just pick it up for them or to
apologize for it
doesn't actually it's not in service to
to the consumer
what i what we really really want is the
challenge that's why we play games we
want a challenge we don't want the boss
to lay down we want to beat it
yeah i was going to say actually that's
wayne i don't think that's actually true
yeah
you can say that to austin wintery yes
you can say that like austin's at the
roof
[Laughter]
in front of austin actually that's the
whole people austin
the my my whole career was started
off by tgc's first game flow
which was the number one inspiration for
flow was
gta's dynamic difficulty system where if
i just wanted to drive around
and chill the game would pose no
challenge it would get out of my way and
let me drive
genova was so inspired by that that you
didn't go and toggle difficulty settings
or you didn't enter into the arena to
start combat
you just played the game and if you
pushed it pushed back and if you didn't
push it didn't push back
and with degrees of gradation in between
that to him was
really elegant design and he said can i
make that but in a in an emotionally
relaxing
way instead of an antagonistic way
because he felt
there were too few emotions being
explored by games in general and
hence he goes on to make flower and
journey thereafter
but i agree with that like i i want a
game to kind of
grant me the kind of experience that i
want
but to go but that's exactly that's
directly contradicting what you just
said isn't it
no i don't think it's just a traveler
traveler traveler in that moment wanted
to have it handed to him and you said no
right i think the difference would be in
if you just you don't want to play the
game
you want to have your own experience i
want to use that that's emergent
gameplay
to me that is i don't want to go off and
do a quest
right now i just want to fish that is
using the platform and the tools that
are available to me within the world
to be able to kind of like curate my my
own bespoke
experience but if you're like i want to
play the game he's like great this is a
boss battle's like
no i just want to be able to just move
past him and have the boss step to the
side and let me
advance from level three to level
assassin's creed's letting people do
that now in a way that i think i was
going to say isn't that the entire
selling point of undertale also
yeah the mega massive
giant hit on the basis that basically
all that content is optional
yeah i don't know if that's maybe i mean
who am i to say
it's it's all subjective taste i don't
think that valhalla is an assassin's
creed game at all it's it's
there's nothing else it does doesn't it
but it's just it's it's a completely
different experience
it's a departure right yeah yeah but
they've that's that
that's in a way that is what makes it ac
at this point because black flag had the
same
uh the same sort of critique slash
praise
you know that people people used the
same sentence to praise it and to
pirate game not an assassin's creed game
yeah but don't do this i love getting
drifted i love that movement it's cool
yeah but it's time but it's still
it's it's dragging behind it the carcass
of the dead ones before it that's the
weird part it's like why not just let it
go
yeah but final fantasy it you know what
i mean just put it ironic given that
assassin's creed
is a prince of persia game like that's
the that's the irony right it's a
franchise built out of
you know a failed attempt to do a
rebrand right
so but to be able to say like hey you
don't need the animus anymore we don't
give a [ __ ]
and how dare you yes they 100 percent do
uh why why is it if you get rid of the
animus you have to get rid of danny
wallace
and danny wallace's core to the
assassin's creed experience good point
i i will also say in my experience on
syndicate
one of the funny sort of trivias about
the music in that game is that i didn't
write a single piece of music for the
present day
a hundred percent of the score is to be
found
in the core gameplay of and the reason
why
was because there was virtually nothing
there was virtually nothing is a bug
that i wrote a lot of music actually i
just didn't play
both stay [ __ ] pc players didn't have
to worry about it though yeah
the um they they told me they said you
know there's so little of the present
day story and we're just going to do it
all
kind of you know cinema verite like that
will be part of what distinguishes
the modern day story which is like point
five percent of the game
um is mostly cut scenes honestly uh and
um
and we didn't score them uh so the whole
the they they recognized players love
and we love making
these period piece explorations of
of a time a place a city that kind of
thing um
and but there is still that very
gentle tie very loose single thread
connecting to the the present day story
and the animus and the
the freaking aliens or whatever and it's
so insane
uh by this point it's so they're their
whole adam and eve i think i've been
here
with him before they do golden apple
i'm the one fan of the modern day stuff
in sanskrit i love it every single time
i'm excited for when they first go to
the modern day and sunscreen
i've gotta be the only one because i've
never met anyone else i was really into
it and then it broke
i was super into it and then they
decided
three hurt me yeah well three broke me
as well
but it was also like even two was like
why am i
fighting over the credit scene like
sequence at the end oh that was great
with the cyber swords oh i love it no
that's that's
no end of two sticks is you're not
you're fighting the the
the modern day templars and
i know that you fight the pope at the
end of that game three
no that's true is that three you're
thinking positive at the end of two you
fight the pub
yeah azzetsia yeah okay okay
one did you fight uh what's his name
fights the the bad man wouldn't make
sense for three anyway because isn't
three like revolutionary war
so no that was still a pope there was
still a pope
stole a pope you fly
but at the end and you go back and all
of a sudden you're now playing as
desmond
yes and you realize like i could do all
[ __ ] no
it's like this big maybe you're doing
all of the
creed stuff desmond you're doing all of
it but then all of a sudden it's like
credits are rolling and i'm like i'm
trying to
like fight these dudes on a big white
shot it's just weird i was like
i can see that pitch
i don't know man i have i have trouble
with assassin's creed because
it was so close to being the best sci-fi
trilogy story
ever and then they were like what if we
annualized it and it just
broke my heart because i loved what they
had built um i loved all the people who
came before stuff stefan
anyway i have to get back to work um so
i'm going to do that
thank you everyone for watching we are
not gonna have an episode next week
because it's christmas
um we will be back i guess on the first
um our christmas gift to everyone is our
absolute austin's wearing album
oh it's gone now you have like a little
it does look like that sometimes doesn't
it yes
yeah it does oh it's coming back um but
yeah
i like it i like that the mic uh
sort of it's really yeah i'm yeah
it's really weird the way reality kind
of
yeah i'm really enjoying you can tell i
don't play with backgrounds very often
um i wanted to say troy on instagram a
wonderful
2020 for uh listening to this
i hope that we've you know brought you
entertainment this year in a year that
has
has sucked pretty bad not that i think
next year is immediately gonna get
better but uh hopefully it does
thank you for listening thank you for
playing and also for watching
we'll see you guys next time it's clever
clever it wasn't that clever yeah it's
clever i liked it